gonna take five suggestions I'm feeling
really good about this because you guys
have been lovely
so don't let yourselves down by giving
out [ __ ] suggestion sometimes people
like golf or [ __ ] and it's really
boring right I mean you guys would have
loved to the golf and [ __ ] wrap there's
holes so what guys over here what would
you like to hear Iraq that the plague
now you have to be specific sir because
uh many times I think many different
plagues have happened throughout world
history the Black Death okay yeah yeah
not really a niche plague is it um you
went for the big in the big in the Black
Death that's right so the Black Death we
going are we going for the one in the
1600 1300 1300 wasn't the black death
was it that was now's a trick question
that was that was that was the bubonic
plague which obviously replicated for
during the black I've just been a real
Belen now cuz I listened in history I'm
sorry I'm so the the plague in the 1300s
we'll take that cool um guys over there
the Salem witch trials this is so I die
I don't take suggestions that I've had
before that one second that was
suggested about three months ago last
timers in New York so I can't I can't
repeat it that would be cheating you can
come up with an it well no I'm happy to
take syphilis I feel like I should ask
the person who gave Senna which I was
another one as well just I don't want to
be unfair you'll take syphilis the
French Revolution has come up before as
well you guys are treading on very
familiar ground this is confusing
deep-sea fishing okay so the 13 hunt in
the 1300s syphilis deep-sea fishing okay
okay Oh guys you are eating up all of
this half of the rooms the walk of shame
after sleeping with a boy band we'll
combine those guys they've only left you
with one suggestion the Revolutionary
War get shout out all the time that is
the most obvious suggestion
all right I'll be honest with you I have
a YouTube channel where these go up
every week Revolutionary War was shouted
out in this Wednesday in this morning's
video and I'd already taken it just you
know I'm not just batting down
suggestions because I don't like them I
could happily rap out the Revolutionary
War not happily I would cry while
rhyming but so let me just kinda this is
your time to think of a really good one
we have plague in the 1300s deep-sea
fishing the walk of shame after [ __ ]
a boy band syphilis so this is gonna be
I want it to be better than all those
put together glowsticks thank you I
think that was the only thing that could
that could do that I was like what are
they gonna come up with what could it be
other than glow sticks but you have a
particular favorite and girth of the
glow sticks because obviously there's
different you know girth not a mean word
what which would you liked you like the
kind of chunky ones you'd be--you'd
dangle from like a little black string
around your neck would you like the ones
you can turn into bracelets the bracelet
ones okay cool cool an interesting
choice I myself prefer the ones that you
get in you know first aid survival kits
there so this lovely people lovely
people at the Comedy Cellar
now this gave me a little thing called a
freestyle rap that is a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions right I'm gonna check do we
have the beat over there we do this
sounds like the be cool and freestyle
made up none of its prepared none of his
rim he's gonna be about all those things
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
toe-curling ly bad as you are expecting
a middle-class privately educated white
boy to be thank you for your convincing
laughs there
Garrett's been a while set you on fire
like the Salem witch trials but we can't
take that answered the quiz ticking off
the symptoms of syphilis the main one I
hold my lovers clothes I'd be careful
cuz they're gonna lose their nose like
Tycho Brahe he lost his in the jewel not
from syphilis the man was not a fool he
always wore a rubber well a lambskin
from the 15th century went in and
syphilis
I think this [ __ ] is so sick try to take
antibiotics to fix that drip don't come
near
unless you got gonorrhea any other STDs
dauer here I take those pills until my
piss is clear and then I go have sex
with no fear I never leave my dick in my
own hand I'm going out to the concert
boy band
I'm standing in the crowd waving my
erection at all the members of one
direction five is too many for shame I'm
gonna talk about this after Zayn left I
did a little walk of shame with him a
walk out of his mansion with a gym
inside how the heck is he so damn ripped
when I see ronan keating a dip for him
he's from one back in the day ride a
roller coaster life is that way but the
walk of shame
here we know how we feel you spend all
night got the blisters on your heel so
you remove your shoes take them off your
toes walk home with your bare once till
their toes in left hand the other maybe
your handbag you still glammed up
wearing all of the Gladrags like a nice
black dress with the diamante a pride of
stride is what I call it hey don't feel
shame cuz you slept around this time if
you wanna [ __ ] every guy in town every
male body genitals plunder than less you
go back about 700 back in those days
turn hundred plague it would be in your
underwear all splayed out on the death
cards with the blue balls what past body
sink hold you knows you could look under
the armpits rules of pus or the body
cards yo they were never enough they had
to burn them in heaps people say it's
shoddy hygiene no but don't keep the
body in the
take you out it's better for all if you
don't preserve it for a funeral rat
spread the one in 1600 and I say that
was ended by the fire in pudding Lane
the Great Fire of London 360 after it's
been a little circle yeah and after some
mattress when I spin glow sticks golden
it spins round like I've got a little
yo-yo but this one over spring I put it
on my wrist I throw it in the air try to
catch bar miss ah [ __ ]
now some guys come in in the club
picking up my glow sticks and throwing
up those signs waving it around for the
tune I say those are my glow sticks
gimme Mac you soon I wanna return it I
put it in my pocket but again there's a
hole so the glow stick I drop it but
luckily it self-illuminating what
chemicals in there a combination
combining technically it's not the right
word
it's still fun waving you can observe
people on a mouse inside in distress the
holding glow sticks up saying s o s and
you would go and get them and try to
save unless you thought they were having
a mountainside rain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay one last inflow we me wishing I'm
off to the ocean going deep-sea fishing
you can see me picking up kippers and
habit then I kick back on my boat
sleeping in a hammock cuz it helps with
the rocking of the ocean I get seasick
when I feel the motion when I'm in the
Sun apply suntan lotion play on the hook
then you know I just go and I like to
get you know I'm sailing in the schooner
if you are a fish with some sails are
consumed you pick you on the deck being
first mate I go over to you and then I
masturbate but not sexual I masturbate
this is on the hook if you come to my
fish shop you can all look the amazing
things yeah that's a mad wish my
favorite one see bond with the flatfish
yeah you guys are funny thank you so
much my name is Chris Turner I'll see
you guys again soon process
[Applause]